I feel like there's like a glass ceiling
for women because I've hit it if you
skate and you rip then you should just
get what you deserve if like
skateboarding is supposed to be for
everybody if we do actually want any
form of equality or space like we're
gonna have to be villains to create that
space my name is Lacey Baker and I'm a
professional skateboarder I discovered
skateboarding when I was really really
young like two years old I was in foster
care at that time and I would watch my
foster brother escape a mini-ramp and I
just was like immediately obsessed like
I was like I have to do this I started
competing when I was 11 years old when I
was 22 I skated the 2014 X Games in
Austin and that's the year I won the
goal with women and skateboarding
there's like a subculture within a
subculture the ski industry like just
doesn't care about women's skating it's
not equal for example like there is a
skateboard contest series which didn't
use to include women in it but it just
started to however is no prize for first
place is 30 grand and like for the guys
first place is 200 okay I feel like it
should be even because we work just as
hard as the guys
me on skateboards is a company that was
created to like support women in
skateboarding I do my own board graphics
like I do a lot of the other girls board
graphics and like it's rad cuz it's like
skater owned and it's like for us and
it's like bhaiyya
so it's like there's nothing corporate
about it and it feels like like that's
how it's supposed to be even if nothing
comes of like like having asked a career
or like anything like that like I still
have skating and like I believe in being
yourself and like you know just doing
whatever the [ __ ] you want that's what
skating is supposed to be